[Music]
alright guys welcome to the to the class
tonight
my greatest losses is the he's the title
and did a class like this last week
where I went over couple my most
memorable or my case least memorable
games with my chest career and I
prepared a couple more of those for you
guys tonight must be some type of you
know interest generated by the crowd who
goes to a lecture where the focus is
someone else's you know grave defeats
hardships so thankfully you're all here
to enjoy that I decided to take one game
which happened
extremely recently to me and another
game which was a little bit older but
the first game that I'm gonna start with
is a game that I played myself against
my opponent from Nepal named Rajendra
and this was a game played at the
Olympiad last year so 2018 Olympiad
still quite a fresh tournament for me
because I haven't played that many
tournaments after the Olympiad so in
fact it's one of my most recent
tournaments even though it it did happen
last last year quite some months ago now
but I thought it would be a great game
to look at because not only was it a
sort of astonishing defeat but it also
happened on quite a big stage so I got
to share my defeat with thousands of
spectators which is what everyone wants
to do when they lose a game
have everyone watch and there were
specific amount of people who may not
have seen that game and perhaps they're
sitting right here in the audience and I
would act like to include them in the
club of people who've seen this this
horror --fill horriffic and horrible
loss because my opponent was rated 1919
hundreds in the nineteen hundreds and I
was at the time I had achieved my
Grandmaster title I was just under
twenty five hundred so you know I didn't
have many excuses and I had a serious
rating advantage over my opponent about
five hundred plus points and you know
that's that's gonna be a very a very big
upset maybe the biggest upset in fact
I'm sure the biggest upset of his his
career and you know since becoming a GM
you don't expect to lose to to a player
below two thousand you know when you're
when you're not even you know what
barely one year into being a GM you're
supposed to go have a long 30-year
career and then maybe drop a game or two
to some young talent but that didn't
happen my opponent was talented but but
he wasn't young so I was a I was
definitely caught off guard and I'll
I'll show you the game the game here
because it was the first round of the
Olympiad so you know you got your team
colors on travel all the way to Georgia
around the world not Georgia in the
States if you go all the way there you
play your first game against Nepal my
first game in a while all the nerves are
there all the excitement's there and
then you lose so it's not very fun
so because it's not very fun for me and
hoping that this will be fun for you so
yeah I was playing white at the white
pieces decided to start off with c4
basically I'm I'm a little bit out of
shape I haven't studied chess as much as
I'd like to or just don't have the time
to so usually what suffers when you
don't have enough time to studies at the
higher levels as your openings
you get a bit bit lazy with what you
play because you don't want to enter
some of the mainline theory you feel
like other people would know that better
than you so I decided to play c4 and
maybe we would transpose to a d4 line
but I usually play d4 and I decided to
start with c4 just to see what he did
turns out he plays c5 and so I thought
okay we're gonna go for efore and get a
more oxy bind position like this and you
know whether you know or not the more
oxy bind is it's just always this sort
of slight plus for white and really an
enjoyable position so not only was my
opponents so much low-rated but I had
this position that I would be
comfortable with against the strongest
player in the world I mean this is sort
of the best opening position I could ask
for so I was really happy with my
opening and then I have even less
excuses so we're playing the maracas see
here knight c6 Bishop e3 I'm trying to
avoid playing the move Knight takes c6
if I can black sort of plays B takes
fixes his structure and of course with
rook b8 and this Bishop here my pawn on
b2 is a little uncomfortable so trying
to support that night in the center with
my bishop and develop the rest of my
pieces basically as you see in the game
now my opponent also doesn't really
commit too many mistakes in this game so
it's it really comes down it comes down
to me after Knight f6 which is one of
the normal ways to start Black has one
line which he can play after Knight c3
instead of the move d6 sometimes people
try this line Knight g4
what's the idea well that is a free
night but then we can take that night in
the center and after Queen d1 just to
stop night c2 there and to get out of
some d5 move by black black plays in
let's say Knight back to c6 and we've
got the same position except a pair of
Knights have been traded so sometimes
black goes for this line sometimes he
just plays d6 keeps all the pieces on
the board in this particular game
my opponent decided to just play the
main line which is just let's say d6
here again if I take blacks always
taking with the pawns so the pawn on d6
is there to stop white from playing B 5
and a lot of lines like Knight takes c6
pawn takes c6 e 5 can be annoying for
this knight on f6 so Bishop e2 just
getting developed normally here
eventually I may play let's say pawn f3
Queen d2 Castle and then just bring the
rooks into the middle of the board and
when you have this this maroc C
structure and when I say me Roxy of
course what I'm referring to are the
pawns in the center of the board that
sort of characterized it this way as
long as I have these pawns here it's
really hard for black to break with b5
and d5 it's also not in blacks interests
to play e5 because then the pawn on d6
would be a target for my queen or any of
my pieces on the open file so really the
idea is is that I want to make blacks
life difficult in terms of breaks so I
want to prevent b5 I want to prevent D v
e5 is not possible and f5 is a little
bit difficult to achieve because of
course we've got that night there and
I've also got my knight and my pawn
watching that square it's not like a
Kings Indian where you just play a 5 in
attack so all these things consider this
is what makes the Marazzi such a
pleasant position to play for white now
not to say that it's a bad position or
even shouldn't be played for black but
it's definitely that slight Plus that I
think any strong player will will be
happy to take against anyone else so I
couldn't complain out of the opening a
castled
Knight takes d4 Bishop takes d4 and
Bishop e6 one of the sort of main ways
to play as black is also this move
Bishop d7 which could be included let's
say before the last move Bishop d7 let's
imagine I played Queen d2 and in similar
style Knight takes Knight Bishop takes
Bishop c6 and this is the other popular
way to play bring the bishop d c6 hit
that pawn let's say that f3 gets played
now black might continue
with 97 and try to trade these bishops
now believe it or not you know white
sometimes with the bishop on d3 Queen d2
wants to play Bishop h6 but in this
particular case this is an example of
when I would actually want to keep that
Bishop and not trade it so usually play
continues Bishop e3 a5 to stop b4 so
black is preparing night c5 and black
wants to put the knight on c5 get the
Queen developed he's got a strong bishop
and trying to play like he has control
of the dark squares there so this is
actually what I was expecting when I
when I saw the opening it's I think by
far the main way to play and although he
took my knight first I wasn't sure if he
was just gonna try to transpose with
either like a 5 or a Bishop d7 Bishop c6
here so I thought it's still reasonable
that he might play Bishop d7 instead he
played Bishop e6 so a little bit
different definitely not not something
I'm I'm afraid of dealing with because
without the bishop on c6 there's less
pressure on e4 and he's deciding to put
a little more pressure on c4 maybe rook
c8 next hitting that pond I'm gonna have
to play b3 and a good move to play
before b3 a lot of the time is like rook
c1 or Queen d2 make sure that knights
protected and they're there art isn't
any trickery on the long diagonal so
after Bishop e6 I decided to play rook
e1 and my only explanation for rook e1
as opposed to f3 is that I was actually
maybe considering some positions where I
don't move my F pawn to f3 and said I
leave it on f2 just play Bishop f1 and
if we look at for example a position
like this bishop f1 let's imagine black
does the same thing I mentioned earlier
usually we don't want to trade these
pieces but I was curious about a
position where maybe I I trade maybe
even give this check and play something
like rook III maybe I want to play my F
pawn off the board
there are also some ideas like putting
the Queen back and somehow trying to get
the Queen to h6 and sneakily use the
rook on the
as well so I guess because I had so
recently studied some position that
looked something like this
I I had this master plan in my head that
I was going to play without my F pawn on
f3 or at least try to so that is my only
explanation for rook e1 otherwise Queen
d2 F 3 B 3 rook c1 all these moves make
a lot of sense here so it's not to say
that my move is the best or or even one
of the best a6 was what he decided to
play okay just followed my plan Bishop
f1 rook c8 so he was playing it a little
bit different than I was used to he
didn't play for this a5 with 9oc 5
instead he's just attacking my C pawn
and maybe has the idea to play b5 in
some cases so sometimes when you play b3
really early you run into positions
where this night might be a little loose
with all these pieces attacking so I
think that I mean if I my rook was on c1
I'd be more confident playing b3 but
this this pressure on c4 caused me to
play in this position 95 but by no means
was i viewing this move as a concession
I was actually quite happy to play this
and I thought with my rook placed so
well on e 1 that almost any exchange on
d5 would be good for me now if the
knight takes then I would most likely
take back with the e pawn and I would
try to use this rook on e1 and put
pressure on this pawn so the bishop
would move let's say I do this and give
a nice check on d4 centralize my queen
let's say King g8 I could do something
crazy like g4 I could do something a
little less crazy like maybe h4 h5 I
could also just play rook III followed
by rook e1 and there's gonna be a lot of
pressure on this pawn and I think that's
the pressure on the e pawn is actually
enough of a reason that I should be
better here so I was comfortable trading
all these pieces but just having that
classic maroc C position where
after 95 you take with the pawn and E
754
although black can sometimes achieve
positions like this let's say where you
get the night you want to put on c5 and
say that the bishop is no good that it's
a bad Bishop and that the knight is
actually a strong night on the dark
squares now although this is possible
again I think you'll find that the dark
squares are just too weak say rookie 3
rookie 1 a lot of pressure here and with
this H pawn coming up the board the
Queen operating on the Kings side it's
really hard for black to to do anything
because you put that night on c5 let's
imagine a 5 to stop b4 and let's say
that you you get that night there you
know clap clap congratulate
you
prettier by the minute okay but the
reason that you know it's it's not
actually doing that much it's just
standing there and looking pretty is
because black doesn't have any threats
he just has a nice-looking night me I'm
actually creating threats I have enough
pressure here that I'm keeping the Queen
and rook tied down and simply move like
h5 is so hard to deal with because
taking always gets mated Queen on h8
next move and if I don't take not only
could I could white do this next I could
play h6 and I'm actually going to create
a lot of threats against the black king
here so these types of positions are the
ones I was going for always taking with
the e pawn each takes d5 opening up my
rook and putting pressure on e7 no
matter what minor pieces would be left
over so after Knight d5 my opponent play
Knight d7 and sort of after the lines
that we just looked at you know in
hindsight maybe even during the game I
think I thought that this was a
reasonable move earlier we were
discussing that 97 Trading the dark
square Bishop was actually a major plan
that the black hat so I could understand
97 so I decided to take and here I
decided to play a for preventing b5 for
good and again saying that if you take
I'm gonna take back and I know that I
have all these weak dark squares so even
the move a 5 can sort of right fix all
these poems on light squares b3 it's
fixed but I wanted to do the same thing
somehow double my rooks on the e-file
maybe Queen d4 and start pushing the
sage fund and I was sort of confident in
handling those types of positions where
at where I'm attacking so you played a5
in reaction and notice he's not playing
Bishop takes Knight he didn't play
Bishop takes Knight yet and so you know
I don't have the exact same rookie 3 h4
h5 I can't just go crazy attacking maybe
until he decides to make that trade so I
decided to check f6 and rook III so h4
h5 maybe I'm gonna go for that but
rookie 3 I thought was nice because
maybe I'll double maybe I'll even swing
to be
three in some crazy variations but I
think the rook on e3 is sort of well
placed so I thought I'd put it there and
then think about it after and also I did
want to play a move like b3 so I'm just
gonna make a nothing move for black
because I did want to play something
like b3 where it just watches everything
and the only weakness in my position is
maybe that pawn on b3 he could attack it
with Knight c5 so I like that the rook
was taking care of that pawn and that
now my rook on a1 was free to to join
the game join the center after rook III
my opponent played Bishop f7 and it
seemed to me here that he truly had no
intention of playing Bishop takes Knight
Bishop takes Knight here is also you
know 10 times worse than it was before
because now we're staring at a position
where they played f6 so now that pawn on
g7 is truly a sitting duck
'if I've is never possible because I
just take it and if you don't play you 5
and you just leave that pawn there I
mean it's very very uncomfortable to to
defend all the time now you wish that
maybe you could stick a knight on e5 but
f4 is always gonna be kicking the knight
out and the pawn on g7 is just too weak
so those are the positions I was
counting on but Bishop f7 I played my b3
move Knight c5 was played hitting my
pawn and ok I decided well I'll just
move my rook I played to move rook b1 I
think I had a lot of ways that I could
have played this position like even just
rook rook e1 was an option but what I
found very annoying here was my desired
rook e1 I was thinking wait a minute
what what if my opponent plays c6 kind
of a strange move he's sort of playing
Connect four here and winning and after
Knight f4 while I would lose my Knight
to e5 and also after Knight c3 well I
would lose my my pawn on b3 tonight
takes b3 so all of a sudden I was in a
position where I felt like I was
compelled to play rook b1 and you know
in the Marazzi I guess there's not many
times where white is almost forced to
play a certain move
and I felt a little strange at the board
when this happened I just felt like well
work be ones not a bad move so I'm fine
to play it but it's not usual that that
I'm sort of forced to play these moves
that that black is sort of kicking me
out and forcing me back I'm playing a
bit of Defense so is at this point where
I sort of realized things maybe were not
out of control but maybe on the wrong
trajectory going down the wrong path you
still followed up with e six as we
looked at earlier I lose my knight if I
play Knight f4 so yeah I have to play
this although I wasn't disappointed
because Knight b5 is an idea and the
knight does sort of protect everything
from c3 and you play Queen b6 here and
he's not threatening to play Knight
takes b3 right because I'm pinning that
that night there and I saw that and so I
was I was comfortable and in this
position I thought well if Knight takes
b3 isn't a threat you know he played
this a six move he still has his Bishop
which is not looking great on f7 so I
thought maybe now is the right time to
continue my my attack on the King side I
always wanted to play ch4 in this game
and I can't really move this and a rook
from b1 moving this Knight I don't
really see the benefit of like Knight e
to or anything like that and so I
decided okay I don't see his threats I'm
just gonna play h4 h5 and continue from
here and there's actually this move
which this next move I played which cost
me maybe cost me the game right here
although I never expected just losing a
pawn to a 1900 that he would have
necessarily the technique to to put me
away but he did after playing h4 i i
blundered kind of like an elementary
tactic in a way but a tactic that
completely escaped me in this position
because i had never seen this exact
orientation of pieces and i wasn't used
to this tactic in this opening not at
all but the tactic is is the same as
in the opening when someone is pinning a
night with a bishop and there's a bishop
right behind the knight
so it means I can move my knight to a
square that protects my bishop and then
capture back the tactic being Knight a
four so then I want to take his knight
but my queen is hanging and if I want to
take his Queen and then take his Knight
well he's got it all worked out because
it's Knight then captures back and gets
out of trouble so if you think back to
the opening let's say if this was a
LightSquared Bishop and that was a dark
square Bishop it's really common to see
someone pinning a knight and then later
on forgetting that if they don't defend
that bishop or in this case that Queen
there's often a sacrifice like this
where you come right back and take and
get your knight out of danger so I just
completely sort of forgot that that this
was possible and it definitely came as a
big shock I mean it was my first first
game at the Olympiad you know sitting
down touching 3d pieces again after
playing online for a little while and
just blendering a tactic that I would
expect myself not to blunder most of the
time and the worst part is that it
nearly forces it either forces the
exchange of Queens with the exchange of
nights so it's just more pieces start
vacuuming off the board as well which is
also again not what I want so it's like
that really unfortunate situation where
you know you're not only losing material
but there's trades that have to come
with it
so is the the worst of everything here I
decided that my best chance was to take
the Queen's off and say that the night
on b6 was not very well placed and that
you know it would take him a while to
get it back here and he's got this pawn
hanging maybe I can pressure the D pawn
as well so I have to say from from this
point rook a one I honestly did not
expect to lose I didn't I thought that
that I would maybe draw now I've
reserved some hope that I might win the
game I think everybody in chess
naturally reserves that hope when you're
calculating or anything like that
but I almost a hundred or very close to
100% didn't think I was going to lose
because quite honestly at 1900 to have
the the ability to I would play a
grandmaster
he's quite impressive and that's why I
was so impressed by this game overall is
is that he he really demonstrated some
accuracy with the next part of his game
and also just even in the endgame when
the time got low I mean he was just
consistent the whole way I felt like he
didn't make any serious blenders from
here on out and I thought that was very
impressive for his rating so he defends
the pawn which maybe is not that
impressive Knight b5 attacking the next
pawns okay he defends it again we're
still still in an imposition that you
know he's just making reactive moves
it's not nothing special
so after Knight there rook c8 I go
Knight back with the idea that of course
I will take a draw I'm down upon if he
goes back there I'll play Knight back to
c7 and if you plays work a7 I can even
go Knight back to b5 work a six-night
back to c7 so his rook doesn't have
anywhere in the a file I can stay safely
so it has to stand the C foul but then
after Knight back to b5 I'm hitting his
a pawn so again he plays a nice move
here it's a 4 he gives up this week pawn
in exchange for a different one and it's
not much I can do I'm sort of forced
into this line and then what I decided
to do was okay there is his extra pawn
it's sitting on d5 it's protected by the
bishop so it he's definitely a clear
pawn up no question but I thought ok
I'll I'll pretend I'm on d4 with my
knight maybe in some moment I'll take
this guy and play like a knight against
Bishop wasn't sure about that but I
thought at the very least I will
blockade the D pawn with my night and I
should have some counter play maybe
against this B pawn on the open B file
or maybe I can pressure the D pawn by
bringing my rooks to the D file so again
I was sort of happy with how this
developed so we go forward a little bit
f3 to stop rookie for I thought I'd get
my King out maybe my bishop out and
again this rook is sort of doing double
dooty here rook c8 Thank You rook c8 and
we sort of reached this position now
I'll just mention that we're on move 34
often in when you're looking over games
it's important to realise sort of when
you get close to move 40 because that
explains a lot of repetitions of moves
or a lot of blunders because you can
sort of assume that players are in time
pressure so that explains why in this
position that we we sort of repeated
here and then if my opponent would play
one more time rooks e7 well it would
just be a draw but he doesn't he plays
95 and the reason that of course we
shuffled there was that he wanted to
just get closer to move 40 so wouldn't
blend or anything in time pressure so
not only was my opponent playing like
very well very accurate holding on to
his extra pawn but he was also like
handling time pressure very maturely you
know this is a smart decision waste some
some moves by repetition and then just
play a different one so he plays a 95 he
has an idea to maybe in some cases try
to arrange knight c6 which would finally
get rid of that blockade I played rook
d5 and although he got a trade of rooks
here I thought that I still have good
pressure against both of these pawns
let's say I left the rook on b5 it looks
like if I'm attacking both those pawns
is really tough for black to make
progress so finally after Knight d5
Knight b2 was played and initially I was
actually ready for this move I thought
okay I'll play a5 get my pawn on a dark
square and this move Bishop e2 was
played to take away all the squares the
knight wants to go too so if the knight
wants to get out it's going back to c4
or maybe a four where I'm not sure where
it's going after that so it was actually
again at this point then once again I
found myself very impressed by my
opponent played rook d7 and I played
King III and after d4 check I'm curious
maybe if anyone here can tell me why I
eventually realized sadly that Knight
takes d4 by me is not a good move
because I had planned to play
takes d4 why is it no good
because this was almost the nail in the
coffin for me he's like I thought that
his pawn had to stay on d5 and then I
would have a dark square blockade and
because I didn't then the pawn starts to
roll all the way down the board as you
can see that night on b2 so well placed
controlling not only the next pawn move
but also the queening square so this
pawn just starts to take off down the
board but I was planning to take it so
what's wrong with this move yeah and
then King efore and then King takes that
for
I mean f4 is the move that you know
doesn't feel right because if King takes
that for I lose my knight on d4 King e4
though
was this was what I calculated and I
stopped my calculation here and I said
if rook check on e7 then King takes on
f4 and now his rook is not back on d7
where it could take my knight so I
thought okay I'm solving my problem
that's what I calculated I stopped there
he calculated a few moves further which
is why he played d4 so what did I miss
in this position mm-hmm yeah rook takes
e2 is really annoying
now the knight takes and I just lose my
rook and we're just down a piece here
and I don't even have like you know a
rook check to to get my rook out of the
the check here out of harm's way so
everything just works for him but again
if I'm down upon it makes sense that
tactics worked for my opponent not for
me chess is a pretty fair game if I've
been on the backfoot the whole game it's
not very logical that I deserve all the
tactics in the world to just be working
for me that wouldn't be fair so they
work for him of course they do d4 this
is what I missed I thought I could take
that pawn he played it sort of quickly
and with some confidence that that
showed me his calculation skills were
also good so I mean he found the tactic
to win a pawn earlier seemed to handle
time pressure very well all of a sudden
he's calculating better than me now I
thought okay that's this is where we
lose the game this is where I was sure
not sure but I felt that there were real
real chances to lose because look how
far that pawn crept up the board all
because I thought I was stopping it at
one checkpoint but if I if you break
through that then he just goes all the
way 93 hits the bishop prepares d2 and I
thought king d2 was the only move and
instead of taking my pawn here and just
sort of winning another pond again he
plays the move that's the most forcing
after d2 Bishop b3 is a is a threat I
mean a winning a winning move
so I simply have to protect it rook d5
and now he wants to take my pawn on a
five I can't do anything about that if
he took it right away though I would
take on d2 so he goes here threatening
to give the same check and again don't
have a choice I can't allow it but now
he can take and I can't play King takes
because now my Knights hanging so again
even this series of moves I thought was
very accurate bye-bye black 91 rook a
for now again after night b1 if if he
played rook here let's say the reason
this is a natural move is because I
can't play King takes or Knight takes
but what I was planning was rook here
hitting his pawn threatening to take on
d2 and what he decided to do was play
rock a4 so that well if I move my rook
somewhere else then after the rook comes
down here I don't have my nice rook
before move and if let's say I decided
to take he was confident that this was
winning and I'm inclined to believe him
not only can he fix my pawns on light
squares here which is very very good for
for black but he's got an outside pass
pawn and this pawn is looking a little
weak probably the King will have some
sort of Avenue into my Kings side here
where he's gonna take all my pawns so I
thought okay four was again a really
nice move I decided play Brooke c7 okay
if here then I just take on b7 again a
nice move Bishop c6 I don't really sort
of have time to go pickpocketing down
here because where k1 is gonna win the
game so now I took and the rook on a4 so
well placed takes on h4 now h7 is
protected so you can see my frustration
is that between the two of us one of us
was playing like a GM and it wasn't me
which was quite frustrating my opponent
was just playing very well he ate was
covering everything watching all the
counter play this part of the game is
just a little bit of sort of technique
conversion
I'm down two ponds here plus you know
everything else that's wrong with the
position so just go a little bit fast
through this because all these moves are
just me sort of trying to drum up some
counter play in him watching the counter
play with with every move even this this
moment here after rook d6 there was no
way for me to take this pond safely if
Knight takes then King f6 I thought and
I'm gonna lose one of these pieces and
if ruck takes well then rook takes let's
say Knight takes and I thought that this
King just goes to d4 and I'm not sure
how I can stop this pawn going down the
board so I was a little bit concerned in
in a lot of lines here that that I would
just be be losing so continuing with the
game everything's sort of protected for
him he's doing a great job stopping my
counter play finally I have this idea
here that I'm trying to get his King
like boxed in and I accomplished that
with King e5 so you know I'm starting to
get excited here right 94s checkmate but
of course my opponent too good has this
one covered as well he gives up his rook
and even here I had my dreams that this
might be a draw but after he gets that
pawn going it becomes very clear here
that it's just not going to work as
there's too many pawns queening for my
rook to stop
and after he makes a queen I had maybe
one loss you know
candle lit hope rook b5 take here
somehow try to get my rook near my pawn
here maybe on g4 try to say that I have
a fortress I don't believe I do but that
was the last try but again with pinpoint
accuracy
my opponent can't go here or here or
here because of queen f1 check or
Queenie to check winning my rook so I'm
forced to go here another thing is that
let's say in this position g5 I can't
take the pawn of course because many
checks will win my rook and what he does
is he forces me away from my own pond
and and wins just from that now he's
gonna win my pawn and he's got this guy
going to make a queen and so I decided
to resign here to where maybe it's been
lost for a while but he finally just
demonstrated complete technique and got
my king away from the pawn now there's
no hope because he's gonna get another
Queen I'm gonna have to sacrifice my
rook at best and that's that so I mean
basically my opponent won upon and then
never turned around like he never looked
back he was able to handle all the
counter play I mean I was trying my best
to go for repetitions try to win some
material back I never thought that it
was an easy conversion up until probably
the the critical moment was when I
missed d4 but even still in that
critical moment he was up to task
he played d4 he calculated it out and I
guess I never stopped being impressed
well this is all retroactive I can
definitely tell you during the game I
was not putting my opponent on a
pedestal wasn't too impressed with him
during the game because I was trying to
find the positive side where maybe I had
a chance but after the game I sort of
realized that he actually just played
quite incredibly and didn't give me a
chance to drum up any counter play or
come back from losing this pawn so I
felt like after I lost the pawn that he
nearly played a flawless game and
and I find that for for my opponent
rated just nineteen nineteen hundred
something to be very impressive so this
was like a big shock obviously the worst
way to start the Olympiad representing
your country
we're playing DePaul huge rating
underdogs you know five six hundred
points deficits on like almost every
board and to lose I mean we still won
the match of course because everyone
else won their games but it's just a
knock on my chest that should never
happen really shouldn't happen so this
was up definitely up there with one of
my most recent memorable losses and my
opponent actually went on to I believe
achieved some sort of title in in the
tournament because his Olympiad result
was so good I think he performed around
2400 so he didn't just do that to me he
did that to everyone else in the
tournament and he ended up achieving
some title whether it was candidate
master or feed a master I can't remember
but he actually earned a title awarded
to him because his performance was so
good in the Olympiad so again the other
weird thing about it was that he wasn't
necessarily a very young player this
might be normal for someone who's like
10 years old because we got we got kids
like the ones in here right now who you
know they could be they could be higher
rated than so many like than me when I
was 10 for sure and you know just have
so many talented kids these days that if
I'm gonna lose to a 1900 I almost expect
it to be maybe the next big talent or
somebody who's studying chess and you
know up and coming but you said it was a
guy who just you know probably had an
office job back home and on his spare
time he just beats GM's apparently so
III wasn't aware of that but he
destroyed me in this game and very
memorable for me very bad memory for me
I don't know if I can go so far as to
say I look back and laugh at it but at
least I can look back at it you know
with both eyes open now
so yeah this was quite a bad loss that I
suffered at a very big tournament very
big stage thankfully for me I recovered
my tournament with some wins near the
end but this one will never really be
for forgotten definitely one of the
lowest ratings I've ever lost to in
terms of difference between my rating so
point differential and especially since
becoming a GM like I was saying earlier
you never expect to have such a such a
you know big upset loss you know right
after you become a GM it's like you join
the club and everyone's like welcome you
know and then you go out there and you
you lose for 1900 and they want to kick
you out again so this was this was a
pretty bad game that I that I suffered
but I have another I have another one
that I wanted to share with you as well
yeah this was not my first-ever Olympiad
but it was my first ever Olympiad as a
grandmaster so I had played in the
Olympiad in 2014 in Tromso for 14 Canada
when I was in I am and I had played not
played but rather coached the women's
team for Team Canada in 2016 and so this
was the first Olympia that I played yeah
as a GM let's say so I get another
reason that it's not a good way to start
off not a good way to start off
okay maybe I'm too scared to play c4
again well technically the answer to
your question is actually probably no
because I just haven't played that much
at all so maybe it's not because I'm too
scared to play it but the answer is
actually yes I haven't played it since
then so maybe subconsciously I'm just
too afraid to afraid to do it again
especially against the 1900 maybe I feel
now more confident against GM's than I
do against 1900 as a result of this
scarring memory but you know losing with
the white pieces is another thing that
most high rated players consider to be a
big advantage the maroc C bind also one
of the most favorite openings for white
so you know when I lost this game it I
just didn't have many excuses like hey I
guess I was tired I don't know like I'm
running running out of things to say but
it was very well played game by my
opponent usually you expect a 1900 to
make a mistake at some point but but he
just you just never seemed to so I made
more mistakes in him and yeah he
definitely deserved it so yeah but yeah
I I have another another game of mine
which you can imagine I'm brimming with
enthusiasm to show you this game
happened in 2015 so this was before I
was a grandmaster and I was actually
playing a grandmaster I was playing
Alexander Donne chenko that's a
grandmaster from Germany he he's he's a
fairly young grandmaster him and I have
actually played a few times in our
careers and that's just because I have
played some tournaments in Europe and
I've sort of crossed paths with him at
at various open tournaments and such and
we always seem to meet in the tournament
when you know maybe I'm off to a good
start or maybe I whenever I really need
a point I always seem to meet this
particular grandmaster alexander
dyachenko you can see here he's 25 88
but he hovers around 2600 and he's
younger than myself so very very
talented player there's a lot of young
GM's from Germany that are studying
chess together and working quite hard
travelling for it
and I played him in a tournament in
France called the vonda open and this
was in 2015 like I said so not
incredibly recent but still still a game
that I remember now
I was playing black in this game he
started with c4 and I actually at the
time had the c5 move that I play but
like I said my opponent I had I actually
met in a few tournaments already so some
of the opening is a little bit of sort
of psychology that he knew maybe what I
had already played and maybe we've
already had a game here and what he
decided to go for it was a line where he
knows that I maybe was going to play the
hedgehog I was and in some of the
Hedgehog lines where you play Knight f3
early black can really quickly put a
bishop on b7
so I think he knew this about my
repertoire at the time and he played
very quickly g3 Bishop g2 so he didn't
let that happen not that this is like
how to beat the the opening or something
but specifically it was like how to beat
my opening so I always put my Bishop on
b7 pretty early and I I found it
annoying when when players did this so
and he did that so obviously he had done
some research and some preparation
so he goes for this move d4 if you don't
play d4 in some cases I might play the
move d4 and the reason he's doing so is
to create a position where I'm probably
going to be saddled with an isolated
pawn no matter what and and the play
continued like this Knight f3 usually
whether it's white or black who has
these pawns what you do is you follow up
with this Bishop move because one of a
couple things is going to happen first
of all nice c3 is not possible we can
see this Bishop d2 is going to mean that
I play move like Bishop c5 and then all
of a sudden your queen is not attacking
the pawn anymore so I'm like coaxing
your Bishop to go to a square that maybe
it doesn't want to be on if Knight d2
well then I don't even have to move my
bishop again it's not attacked and the
Queen is not attacking upon so for a
couple reasons Bishop before is is a
very standard type of move you okay he
goes with Knight bTW to knight c6 so
guarding my pawn also guarding my bishop
sometimes we might worry that you know
that bishops a little loose too maybe
some tactic like that the knight c6 nice
solid move a3 makes sense hits the
bishop and I wanted to bring my bishop
back to a square where it was always
going to protect the pawn on d4 now am I
expecting to hang on to this pawn for
the rest of the game not really you know
that white is gonna eventually play
Bishop here Knight here
unleash the Queen the knight and the
bishop plus all the other pieces in the
position I mean I'm not hanging out on
to that pawn forever but I am gonna hang
on to it as long as I can without making
any bad moves in my position so this is
what I did here he played Bishop takes
d4 I played rook e8 and it was around
here castles Bishop g4 where I thought
that I have a reasonable position
although these pieces might get traded I
thought that despite my isolated pawn I
have good pressure on the e-file and the
other thing that you have to keep in
mind is I'm trading so many pieces right
the more you trade even though I might
have this weakness the closer we get to
an endgame maybe
and game something like that is it
really going to be enough to lose the
game
that's the question and at the time and
even now I I think the answer is just no
so I was feeling pretty confident here
queen d3 Queen d7 so I gave him a chance
to double my pawns here that might not
look very normal one of the reasons I
did was because this pawn is not on b2
now if it was on b2 then I think I have
a horrible position very very bad the
reason that this is even playable at
least in my head was that this rook is
always going to be attacking a3 and
that's a given for the rest of the game
which means he's always going to have to
have a rope or a queen something
protecting that pawn on a3 and I can
meanwhile shift my rook away from the
pond go back to it whenever I want and
it just always has to be watched over
so that was my compensation for these
double pawns here was that a3 was always
under attack and in the meantime I have
pressure on e 2 here so my opponent has
to do something about that and at the
time I thought well if he plays III then
maybe I have this move
Queeny for so I'm attacking two pieces
here and I'm encouraging him to to take
me on e4 so that I can take back with
one or more you know with the pond with
a knight it doesn't matter and and I
thought that lets say a position like
this let's say rook c8 would actually be
quite decent for me because I'm
threatening to play like rook c3 or just
get my pieces in the position and he
can't necessarily play well maybe he can
but it looks not necessarily clear rook
c1 because once again I might take that
and take on a3 and this is what I was
referring you earlier so that rook
always has that open file so I thought
that was good compensation even if my
pawns don't look very good I thought
that open file must be worth something I
sort of overlooked h3 at the time I have
to admit not that it's a move that you
know Wow brilliancy I totally missed it
but I just sort of overlooked it in my
calculation that he can throw this move
in and that it makes a difference
because if I go into any of the lines I
just looked at all the Queen e4 moves if
my bishops aren't attacking the knight
they're not the same so if my mission
goes back here which
did then III Queeny for is not quite the
same as it was in the other position
although it's still it's still fine and
the reason it's not quite the same is my
opponent can actually play Queen D 1 in
the previous position with a bishop here
walking into that pin though well that
does not seem right that does not seem
right at all but now that the bishops
kicked out Queen D 1 was actually
possible and I guess I hadn't really
anticipated that but I still think it
was a fine position now I still in this
case have this rook on a8 hitting that
pawn I thought that I have the other
open file and I might stick a knight on
e4 very hard to kick out f3 always hangs
the pawn and otherwise he never wants to
give up his bishop for the night that's
not what white wants to do is his King
would be too weak so I still thought
yeah that my pawns look very very bad
very ugly but good position must be a
good position knight on e4 and I thought
okay let's trade if we traded everything
he's not gonna play this move but if he
did I would be hitting this pawn so I
wouldn't just be losing a pawn on e4 and
I also have control over the open file
so I'm the one who can enter the
position whenever I want so he decided
to play Brooks e2 and after takes takes
Queen c8 again I'm renewing this threat
as well as offering a trade sort of
forcing him to to take and go into this
endgame and at this point probably when
I was playing the game I didn't really
realize that this would be in one of my
greatest losses lectures now looking
back that's quite quite sad because I
think what we're looking at here is a
position which I wouldn't consider
completely equal but based on the way
that I handled it in the way that I
played I thought that I was almost
cruising towards a draw I thought that
although my pawns are very weak if we
look at what happened to just bring the
King into the middle and from here it
was very hard for me to see how white
makes progress because what I want to do
is play g5 which I did fix these pawns
like this I like g5 because it's on a
dark square we both my
I have LightSquared Bishop it's a good
rule for end games not that it's always
true but often true put your pawns in
the opposite color of your opponent's
Bishop especially if you both have the
same color Bishop and there everyone's
moving on light squares if your pawns
are all in dark squares then no you
never have to worry about defending them
so that's my logic there if the knight
went to f5 I was probably gonna take it
so I felt like if I traded Bishop for
Knight that's good for me I felt like if
I trade it almost any piece that was
good for me but what I ended up doing
was I thought quite good whenever you're
in a let's say slightly worse position
especially in an endgame it's really
good idea to trade pawns when you can
trading the pawns liquidates the
position it's very hard to win you know
with reduced pawns on the board because
sometimes it may come down to oh you
only have one pawn I'll just sacrifice
my piece for it and then you can't win
so the more pawns traded the better and
although he's got nice looking pawns
nice position I didn't actually see how
he breaks through because my plan is
simple I want to play King here and f5
and trade everything and then go into a
pawn endgame and and say okay it's it's
just over it should be a draw
and unfortunately for him there's not
much he can do about that although these
pawns look weak he can't attack them
that's what's so frustrating
the knight is controlled nicely by this
bishop sort of every square would want
to go that's you know forward progress
if Knight b3 let's imagine right there's
just no getting in to any of the squares
you want how do i attack b6 there's no
good way a four is protected c4 is not
possible hard to get the move f4 in
always drops upon anyway so in this
position he played 92 but after f6 he
goes back to d4 it was clear that that
there wasn't really a plan for for white
and that's fine sometimes you're in an
endgame might be better for you but it's
just not winning and I felt like that's
what this was so it was kind of like if
I lost the game maybe I wouldn't be too
surprised as long as he did it in a nice
way maybe he shows some technique in the
endgame I would played me but I thought
that I could get away with all these
weaknesses but simply trading material
down and I pretty much did so perfectly
and the reason that I took with the
bishop is that if I took with the knight
I just did not want to allow the option
for him to play a position where he's
got a nice night against a bad bishop
where the bishop like we were talking
about can't attack any of these pawns
because they're all sitting on dark
squares so I thought okay what's perfect
for me is taking with the bishop because
if he takes with his knight and we get a
sort of imbalance here I'm comfortable
with this because I'm I'm hitting his
pawn here and I wasn't sure that he
could go for this so what that means is
that if I start by taking with the
bishop actually the most likely
situation is he just has to take me
let's say and so at this position I had
actually sort of reached this position
in my head and realized that my pawn on
b6 is actually fantastically placed
because if king D for
King e6 and there's no invading here
there's no King to c5 and let's save a
for to play a five and try to get King
c5 then I thought well King d6
a five I could take I could push let's
say takes takes one thing I thought
about this position is that yes white is
just going to play this or king b6 let's
say and win the game so I have to be
careful about that
but let's say here King e6 after this if
after a five I play b5 then it would be
White's turn in this position the reason
that maybe taking is is wrong is because
then it's my turn so here if he plays
efore and I would take King takes King
takes or King e6 rather and wherever his
King goes I just sort of follow him if
he plays f4 then the the issue that I
saw was that I could play move like g4
and I would get my King here and use the
d4 move to break up these pawns
like this and surprisingly actually
black is winning the same game so let's
say if he tries to win he plays that for
he runs into this and I had calculated
this but he didn't play king d4 actually
he spent sort of a long time here
because actually there's only King and
pawns on the board it's not much to
think about you can only move so many
pieces right calculate your king moves
calculate your only legal or decent pawn
moves and there you go you've analyzed
the whole position so he probably saw a
king before and saw what what variations
we just looked at on the board and said
okay they don't win so what I'm gonna do
is I'm just gonna play this move so I'm
gonna see what my opponent does maybe he
finds that it's just equal and maybe we
go into this so here if I had played
let's say King f6 we would transpose
after king d4 to King e6 right because
last time we played King from here to
here and King from there to there so
zigzagging like that was exactly like
that's the same for both of us so if I
wanted to transpose I should have
probably played that I think at the time
I was maybe a little concerned about
this and how if I got this position that
he could waste a move and maybe it would
be my turn but it's not really a problem
as after this you know for him to go for
my pawns I also get his pawn and make a
queen of my own
that's another race for another time but
certainly something that I was concerned
about playing King f6 so I thought okay
he shuffled I'm gonna play King e5 and
then after king c3 I'll go back to King
f5 so I played king e5 and I think this
was one of the only times that I've seen
an opponent do a fist bump with his eyes
so I for king e5 he was so happy because
he hasn't moved f4 in this position
which I resigned after this move
because it looks like an impossible move
maybe but quite simply he he takes my
pawn and then he's first to get here and
take the rest of the pawns so it's just
lost all of a sudden because remember in
the past I was saying that where ever my
king was would be somewhere not check
after f4 I was saying g4 was my move
was always ready to play g4 but I sort
of played king e5 without thinking too
much I will also add a footnote that
we're on move 43 so this is even worse
for me because we've already hit time
control so I wished that I lost this
game on move 39 or something more
respectable but move 43 indicates that I
just got extra time and didn't use it so
it's even worse for me we're not looking
good here on the PR side King e5f for
just game over I have to take if I don't
and I go King here well he just takes
here and he's just first again
everywhere so it came all the way down
to King and pawn endgame it's kind of an
important tournament for me of course I
was going for the GM title it was a GM
norm tournament and it all came down you
know not like the penultimate round or
the up you know anything like that this
is just round four but I was off to a
good start obviously since I was playing
a strong player and this really just
sort of set me set me back in the
tournament and okay obviously I never
ended up making a norm in this
tournament didn't go that well but just
these tough defeats that the whole game
it's maybe equal or slightly worse but
should be a draw and then one one move
without thinking at the end king e5 and
you can just resign with that four so
it's just such a thought a shock that I
thought because I was expecting to draw
this entire game it was not my game plan
going in but the way the pieces were
being traded I thought okay I have it I
have a bad bad pawn structure but you
know shouldn't be an issue
I'll be able to make a draw here with
some weak pawns and you know sort of
fight for that equality because I'm not
down any material and it's unless you
make so many weaknesses it's kind of
hard to lose a game when you're
knockdown material but that's why I'm
here to tell you that I found a way I
found the way to do that
I lost without being
down material so I actually resigned in
a position a King and pawn endgame with
equal material that's a well that's a
it's a great loss that's a very
memorable loss and definitely something
that I've sort of reminded me to always
take your time in those end games where
it looks so completely simple the only
king and pawns on the board but all that
means when there's a few pieces on the
board is that your mistakes are are
magnified you know a hundred times that
one wrong move is just game over when
there's a bunch of pieces on the board
you can make a blunder when you can keep
playing I mean it's not game over maybe
after that blunder you might be worse
but then you can try to fight back
there's often no fighting back from
mistakes in King and pawn n games those
mistakes are the ones that you know the
the person who doesn't have a heart rate
you know that's like zero point zero
zero and then you make a bad move and
then just they come alive like some
Frankenstein or something those are the
those are the bad moves and they always
happen in end games so this was another
quite poor loss of mine that's okay I
just had to live with I resigned on the
spot and yeah this was against Alexander
dawn Schenk oh so just messing up in a
simple position against a strong player
is always a tough feeling because you
know when you play those guys that are
high rated in you that's when you want
to score those wins get those points
draw whatever it is just demonstrate
that you can play at a higher level and
this demonstrated that that I was
nowhere close to that level so a tough
loss to take and and yeah both of these
these games today I guess we're losses
in very different ways but both of them
were quite impactful on me and I still
remember them so yeah that's pretty much
it for for this class guys
[Music]